con un golpe de bolígrafo el gobernador
de virginia
jordan puso fin a la pena de muerte en
su estado
[Aplausos]
la legislación aprobada por la asamblea
general controlada por los demócratas
fue la culminación de una larga batalla
para terminar con las ejecuciones en el
estado que según los legisladores ha
sido aplicada de manera desproporcionada
contra personas afro enfermos mentales y
pobres
a lo largo de nuestros 400 años de
historia virginia ha ejecutado a más de
1300 personas más que cualquier otro
estado
tenemos mucho de que estar orgulloso de
la historia de virginia pero no de la
historia de la pena capital a la corte
suprema de estados unidos prohibió la
pena de muerte en 1972 lo que llevó a
muchos estados a promulgar sus propias
leyes el tribunal revocó su decisión
cuatro años después actualmente la pena
capital es legal en 24 estados
23 la han prohibido y los gobernadores
de tres estados han emitido moratorias
sólo superado por texas virginia ha
ejecutado a 113 personas desde que la
corte suprema- restableció la pena de
muerte en 1976 los republicanos del
estado defendieron a pena capital por
crímenes atroces como una forma de hacer
justicia a las familias de las víctimas
pero los detractores señalaron fallas en
el sistema judicial desde 1973 más de
170 personas en eeuu han sido liberadas
del corredor de la muerte tras
descubrirse pruebas de su inocencia los
opositores a la pena de muerte esperan
que el cambio radical de virginia marca
un punto de inflexión en la eliminación
de la pena capital en el sur donde
actualmente se llevan a cabo la mayoría
de las ejecuciones